boycott diplomatique des jeux d'hiver de
pékin plusieurs pays dont les états unis
et le canada ont décidé de n'envoyer
aucun représentant de leur gouvernement
djo boycotter c'est déjà arrivé par le
passé retour sur trois édition
mouvementée
1976 jeux d'été de montréal au canada
[Musique]
pour cette édition 22 pays africains
décident de n'envoyer aucun athlète de
leur pays on parle ici de boycott
sportif ou intégrale la raison la
présence de la nouvelle zélande à ces
jeux les pays africains reproche aux
all-blacks l'équipe de rugby
néo-zélandaise d'avoir participé à une
tournée en afrique du sud pays
pratiquant l'apartheid
parmi les boycotteurs l'egypte le kenya
ou encore le cameroun son président
assumer ce choix politique nous avons
décidé de boycotter les jeux olympiques
de montréal pour des raisons que nous
avons donnée nous estimons que les ces
raisons sont valables
c'est tout ce que je peux
1980 jeux d'été de moscou en urss à
l'époque en pleine guerre froide les
soviétiques viennent d'envahir
l'afghanistan
jimmy carter à leur président des états
unis pose un ultimatum à l'urss c'était
le 20 janvier 1981 sept mois avant le
début des jo j'ai demandé si les troupes
soviétiques n'ont pas évacué
l'afghanistan d'ici un mois que les jeux
olympiques se tienne ailleurs qu'à
moscou qu'il soit transféré à journée ou
même annuler
réponse des soviétiques négative un mois
plus tard le 20 février 1981 les etats
unis se retire définitivement des jo de
moscou j'ai décidé les états unis
participeraient pas à
moins que les forces d'invasion
soviétique ne se retire d'afghanistan
avant le 20 février
ce délai expire demain et il ne sera pas
prolongé une cinquantaine de pays dont
le canada et le japon ont participé au
boycott ils n'ont envoyé aucun athlète
1984 jeux d'été de los angeles aux
etats-unis et quatre ans après le
boycott américain l'urss n'a pas oublié
nous avons décidé de ne pas envoyer de
délégation à los angeles et cette
décision est définitive des soviétiques
appli giot en guise de vengeance douze
pays communistes se joindront à eux dont
l'allemagne de l'est et la bulgarie là
aussi ils n'ont envoyé aucun de leurs
athlètes 24 ans plus tard en 2008 les jo
d'été de pékin avait aussi créé des
tensions plusieurs pays avaient demandé
à boycotter diplomatiquement la
cérémonie d'ouverture est donc un envoyé
aucun représentant de leur gouvernement
finalement 90 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement s'y sont rendus un record à
l'époque
[Musique]